gaston santos senior is famous across
mexico in a 30-year career he's fought
2,000 bulls becoming a legend in a sport
many consider appallingly free is there
no violence in hockey or boxing it's in
our nature we have become predominant in
this planet because of our violence
competitive nature so I see nothing
wrong for violence as part of a
spectator sport most of them are now
retired from the ring santos senior
spends his days training his son in the
lush tropics of central mexico ron chola
Arella is an ideal training ground for
an aspiring bullfighter in these fields
what counts for man and bull is stamina
only courage carries a higher value only
the hardest charging animals are
selected to fight young Gaston has to
learn their behavior gaston won't face
the bull alone Matadors fight on foot
and on their own but an equestrian
bullfighter can rely on a four-foot and
partner purebred Lou sottano horses make
first class fighters naturally fearful
horses must get years of training before
they can dance in the path of a charging
bull the smallest mistake can mean the
difference between life and death in the
southern state of Yucatan a bullfight
draws thousands but this is more than
just death for the sake of spectacle it
is a celebration of valor and artistry
in the face of danger it's a family
event young and old come to watch their
heroes some will cheer for their
favorite bullfighter others for the
Bulls
every time a bullfighter enters the ring
he knows it could be his last
since 1900 nearly 100 men have died
fighting bulls the bull is strong the
spears get shorter and shorter with each
pass Gaston must reach over those deadly
horns and jab the point precisely
between the shoulder boards until now
the spears have only caused flesh wounds
enraging afford the dramas climax is the
death spear a bullfighter has no greater
duty than between kill he has two
chances to do so from horseback the blow
should be quick and exact straight
through to the heart Gaston needs to
dispatch his animal in a set time if he
fails attendants will take it away and
slaughter it a death without dignity and
a great shame to the bullfighter the
clock ticks on and still the bull stands
bloodied but unrelenting Gaston is
running out of time he's had his tries
from horseback now he must try to end
this on foot
Gaston drives the blade home a mortal
wound to a bull that fought the good
fight but could not win the battle death
with honor is still bittersweet another
day in the ring another contest between
life and death
Gaston has proven himself and upheld his
father's legend today but his time in
the spotlight is only starting in a
country where men in his line of work
become heroes and bullfighting is a
national pastime no matter how ardent
its critics